يا لها من مباراة وإذا فاتتك جيدًا
هنا نذهب إلى نهائي كأس العالم نعيش
على مستوى الضجيج ، ثم هزم بعض الأرجنتين
حاملة اللقب فرنسا
بركلات الترجيح المثيرة ، حيث تم
تسجيل النتيجة عند ثلاثة بعد فترة من الوقت الإضافي
شهدت إصابة كل فريق.  الجزء الخلفي
من الشبكة للنجم المهاجم ليونيل ميسي
هو الفداء الذي حصل على لقبه الأول في
كأس العالم في محاولته الخامسة
لدى CNN لدى المراسلين حول العالم مع
رد فعل على هذه المباراة الكلاسيكية الفورية ،
هذا هو المشهد في بوينس آيرس ، حيث
يتجمع الآلاف من مشجعي كرة القدم
للاحتفال.  أعني أنه بحر من
الناس وفي وسطه كل
ستيفانو بانزابان من قناة CNN ، إنه موجود هناك مرتديًا
هذه المادة الشبيهة بالحلويات لأن
الحشد كان في كل مكان وأنت تتنقل
هذه المباراة ذهابًا وإيابًا
كيف يفعل الناس هناك  أعلم أنهم
متحمسون كثيرًا من الإثارة ، إنه مجرد
فهم جاستن ، يمكنك أن
ترى الرجل الذي يقول إنه مجرد فرحة من
الاحتفال
أم أنه انتصار في الأرجنتين
لقد كان المنتخب الوطني
آسفًا ، لقد كنا ننتظر
منذ أكثر من 36 عامًا ، وأخيراً
، لقد انتهى هذا آه ، إنه
مجرد
احتفالك وشغف أمريكا الجنوبية الخالص بكرة
القدم
أم رأينا  المباراة سارت المباراة
أولاً بالطريقة الأرجنتينية ثم
قاموا بتغييرها وتمكنت فرنسا
من إعادته ولكن بعد ذلك ليونيل
ميسي كما قلت ، ابن فريدريكا الضال
، اللاعب الذي غادر الأرجنتين عندما
كان في الثالثة عشرة من عمره ليتعلم كيفية لعب كرة القدم  في
أوروبا تعلمنا كيف نلعب كرة القدم
في برشلونة ونعطي هذا
البلد الفرح الذي كان مفقودًا منذ
أكثر من 36 عامًا أه فريدريكا